if you'd have asked me at the very end
if you'd put a suitcase ten thousand
dollars a thousand miles down the road
and said go on just another thousand i'd
just gone no i'm just be i'm done at
that point where forest turns around and
he says i'm pretty tired i think i'll go
home now i just knew exactly sort of
what he felt like
rob pope welcome to the show
jesus thanks for having me man it's a
very very pleasant reminder to hear that
accent while i'm out here in texas
it's same as well man i hope you hope
you spread the geordie love over there
when i was actually in the states nobody
actually thought i was english by the
way most people thought i was australian
well it's just such a strong accent
right it's not exactly when people think
about britain especially americans they
think about like pip pip tally ho what
what cup of tea governor and then you
come in
[ __ ] hell all right mate what's the
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] is going on there lah
it's not but
i was relying on the scouts acting to
get me out of trouble if i ever got into
a
having like some real [ __ ] you know and
it sort of actually almost got me into
trouble once but uh i'm sure we'll get
to that later tell you what a funny um a
funny story about my accent
in 2006 right i did my first ever boston
madison and if anybody's like done a
marathon sort of in the uk or elsewhere
in the world they've not done boston
you've got to do it it's like the best
mile 13 you've run past wellesley
college which is the biggest all-girl
university in like the united states
probably the world
and when you go down it it's like what
it was like being in the beatles so
everybody's screaming and the signs of
saying we'll kiss any mexican guy we'll
kiss any japanese dude and i saw one i
wasn't going to do a pb and i saw one
would say well kiss any brit and i
thought
yeah i'm going to have a bit of that and
i just i just lent him for the peck and
it ended up being something a little bit
more and i just said so i've got to go
and as i run down the road i had to just
go oh my god he sounds just like prince
william
you've never heard prince william have
you you're so confused
well yeah i mean scouse i understand
what you mean when you say that you rely
on your accent as another layer of
defensive armor because there is
something about the scouse accent which
is essentially weaponized
like it is
it is broadly for the people that are
listening from america or elsewhere that
don't understand to hear rob's accent in
the uk
is to
it's to fear that there's he's got ten
mates and they're all gonna do you in
next to the kebab shop that's kind of
like for instance i wouldn't want to
work with a scouse psychotherapist
talking about my past trauma
what would be the american equivalent
would it be like new jersey or something
like that yeah it's like probably a kind
of an aggressive
um
yeah it probably would be a new jersey
one maybe
but that's the thing as well we're like
the friendliest people like everybody
likes to come to liverpool and then just
like they hear the voice and then
they're just like oh my god and then
they just go where about to your goal
mates i'll take you then i'm still going
there myself just go with me and they're
like oh okay
[ __ ] man so what's your background in
running you mentioned that you did the
boston marathon is is running something
you've done all your life
yeah well i did it at school bizarrely
like liverpool
is such a football city in my schools
one of the schools that didn't play
footy so it was cross country or rugby
in the winter and so i did cross country
because i was too little and uh i did
that at school but when i actually went
to university i switched and played
football
i did a few marathons but i was only
like training in the way that you know
the average person would train to do
madison you know if i was doing a
40-mile week i'd be very happy with that
um but i moved to australia for three
years in
and i decided to join athletics club
just because i wanted to get a circle of
mates and i didn't think so i thought my
football days were over anyway just
because i was getting a bit older
and um i joined this club and it got
really weird because i'm naturally
competitive to the point of which
stresses me out a bit but like i much
prefer to train rather than race but
when i train i train really hard as if
i'm gonna do a race even there's not one
scheduled
and i started getting really quite good
and i ended up getting picked to run for
victoria the state of victoria in the
australian uh madison championships
which is part of the sydney marathon
and then the first mile went really well
and i was throwing it behind this huge
fella uh he was actually on telly he
must have been about six foot six and
that's two meters tall and like he had
these marijuana socks on and uh the
commentary said oh we've got a hometown
here out here and he dropped back and i
thought i was going to drop back with
him but i stayed with these lead guys
and eventually yeah i content in this
sydney marathon
and i go over the line and the coach
from victoria goes congratulations rob
you're australian champion and i was
just like
mate like you know i'm english right
and he goes it doesn't matter mate
you've been here long enough and i go
okay i get to get the medal and i
literally don't say another word until i
get the medal in case somebody just said
excuse me he's not he's not australian
and i got it and i took it off in the
way that often like you know people take
off their second place medal because he
don't want it but i was just taking mine
off so i could put it in my pocket in
case anybody came up and said they've
been a dreadful mistake and i was gonna
go mate i know i've lost it
but i've still got it downstairs i
should have brought it up but um
i think it got more surreal after that
because i'm walking down this street in
sydney and i got a phone call from the
head of athletics australia
and he goes congratulations rob hey you
know today was a double iwf gold race
and i'm just like uh yeah and he goes do
you know what that means and i'm like no
and he goes because you came in the top
10 mate it means you've automatically
qualified for rio and i was just like
well like as in like the olympics not
like the fizzy drink or the or the kids
film
and he's um
and he says yeah and they go what does
that mean does that mean i'm going the
olympics and he goes well no because
there's some other people are going to
try and get the qualifying time but at
the moment only one has got the time and
there's three spaces
so if they don't get the times would you
be prepared to switch nationality and i
was just walking past the tattoo shop as
the call happened and i was thinking
about just going in and getting the the
southern didn't on my arm but uh
unfortunately i think three more got the
time and i was um i was fifth and nobody
got injured so i keep meaning to go and
get that tattoo but i'm gonna get the
olympic rings
but like at the end just dot the last
two out
nearly nearly achieved the olympics yeah
yeah yeah
so
what a great story for the pub though
yeah it's not bad roll me forward from
there then you decide to do this
rather ridiculous journey across america
where did the original idea for this
come from
ah sort of the original idea you know
sort of all the best ideas i think are
slightly plagiarized and then i read a
book
by a fellow called nick boldoff he sadly
isn't with us anymore and then he ran
across america like in the early 2000s
maybe even in the 90s and it was just
such a great story the way he sort of
painted all these landscapes i thought
i'm going to do that one day and i sent
him this email in 2006
and it was entitled forrest gump 2
because of course everybody who runs
across the states you know you're going
to get the followers gun comparisons
and um he was super supportive and said
oh you know these this is all what
you've got to do and you know it's quite
a lot that goes into it and i never
really had enough time and it was only
actually coming back from australia
uh i came back to a job that i thought
was going to be brilliant and it ended
up being not brilliant i didn't have any
time to run and at this point i was
slightly harboring you know ambitions
that i could maybe get to next olympics
you know i thought why not never trained
properly before so let's give it four
years
and then never happened and i thought
i'm not going to get to the olympics on
a three-year training cycle so um i
thought let's do this america run let's
get it done and then the the training
sort of um
didn't really pick up what the planning
did
and i um
i was looking at roots and i had always
had this idea of the forest gumproof and
i remember reading an article in a
newspaper of a guy who completed it
and i thought oh god there's no point
doing it now somebody else has done it
and then i read the article but he's
only done one of the five crossings he'd
gone from santa monica to maine
and i thought
right this is it if i'm reading this
article and thinking oh wow that that
would have been brilliant someone else
is reading that article and we've just
got to go
and we actually
looked at when foreign started which was
september the 15th and this was in march
and we're like right six months that's
probably enough to think about it and
plan in there as it happened there was
another guy who probably read that
article and he was gonna go for it as
well so
it made it a little bit awkward did he
end up doing it he ended up starting it
but um like he had some um well
basically i think we both ran into
problems in houston uh mission control
and all that so mine was with injury and
his with with logistics and
um i don't think he
fancied the solo crossing so early in it
and so um yeah unfortunately he couldn't
continue because it would have been
quite fun to have had a little bit of a
race across the country but it was just
me so
what did the plan to do it look like how
do you begin to plan running across
america five times
well
my original plan was just the athletic
goal and i just thought if i could do
one crossing then i'll always have a
thing to hang my hat on you know that's
just such a great story there's only 300
people who've ever like ran across yeah
and probably like a few more who've like
walked across
um
so i i thought where am i going to start
so greenbow alabama doesn't exist they
made it up for the film
so in the book
forest is from mobile so i thought right
let's start there and it's actually
quite cool because it's only like a
marathon or so away from biola battery
which is where bubba's from so i'm
already going off course
i take a little detour down to the down
to the sea and i see the shrimp and
boats come in and then it's basically
setting the course for santa monica no
real goals on the way i thought i'd love
to go to new orleans uh we had to go
through houston uh because we were going
to be getting an rv there you know
that was a sort of thing then on to
austin uh which is like still one of my
favorite american cities went through
texas to el paso and so this is just all
part of a route to get to santa monica
but from there
you know five times no one's ever done
that no one has ever liked to have run
across america i think four times at
that point you know instead of um
so i was just like right this is gonna
go one step beyond
and there was a chap who'd borrowed a
map from behind the news reader forrest
gump and he calculated pretty much an
entire route and it made it out to be 15
248 miles now i i tinkered with that a
bit because he'd missed out a couple of
waypoints like uh glacier national park
up in the north
and um and i thought i have to hit at
least everything you can find where the
scene was in the film i've got to go
there and so i went down a proper
procrastination wormhole of like such a
bad yeah you know where all these cool
places can i swing by vegas on the way
yeah i probably can
and uh
then the next sort of thing was like how
the dickens are we going to afford this
because um
they reckon when you've got any sort of
expedition like this you should really
plan it at least 18 months out and by
the time we decided we were definitely
going to do we booked the flights we had
like three months and so sponsors were
gonna you know touch you in the barge
pole somebody with yeah i'd run a few
marathons but had no ultra form at all
and
proposing to do something that nobody
had ever done in fact there's like an
article that says like was his run even
physically possible
and so is somebody really going to hang
the hat and somebody who in all honesty
in all likelihood was just going to be a
spectacular or even a
an unspectacular failure because who
wants to tie their company's brand to
that you know oh this is a guy who went
through a run 200 miles later realized
he couldn't hack it you know this is my
this is my brand
and um so we thought we'll get to santa
monica someone will pick it up nah that
didn't happen we'll get to new york
someone will pick it up that didn't
happen and that was the ongoing story so
uh myself and my partner we had saved up
money for a house
and we thought right well that was at
least get us to you know california and
a bit back the other way um
and hopefully that responsible combat
never did and we were
thinking about the best way to do it
which was hiring rv now are you looking
at three grand a month too expensive
hire car and motel still a one-way
transaction
so we gambled on buying this old rv like
a proper like sort of ron burgundy type
special and then selling at the end to
see if we could recoup some of the money
and then even though it didn't work out
like that it gave us enough confidence
to say
let's do it and once we had our 30 foot
long cruise liner we had to at least
make it to the bloody pacific didn't we
and that was all the planning i only had
a 90-day visa i wasn't confident i would
go the the whole five crossings in fact
nadine was the only person who ever
believed that i would
what made you think given your limited
experience at doing ultras
that you would be able to do 15 000
miles
it was a sort of knowledge that people
had run across america before and i've
sort of found that with any sort of like
sport cycle and training it takes you
about a month to get into it i sort of
spoke to a couple of people who
who'd done it
including one guy who's the only guy to
run every london marathon he was an
invaluable source of experience and he
said
the first three weeks will be the test
if you get through the three weeks you
know that is then basically your setup
to do it at you know the pace that
you're going to be able to do it at
and then after that's a question of
hanging on so
the thing is it didn't really matter to
me about
getting much beyond santa monica i'd be
lying if i said i didn't want to if i
had finished after two and a half legs
would i have been disappointed
absolutely
but i think i'd have been able to look
back at it and just go i still did quite
a bit you know i got to chicago you know
that'll do me um
but like
it would have been cool because forrest
didn't set out to run five times across
america it was never his goal
in fact i'm the only person in the world
whose goal it probably was and went out
to actually achieve it um
he just ran until he was tired and i
figured as long as i get the haircut at
the start and then grow the beard and
run till i'm tired that's that's at
least a good tribute was the worst part
of the entire trip getting that haircut
at the beginning that high-end type
thing
it was so weird because like stuff i've
never had short hair before like about
even when i was a little kid so
it was 38 degrees in a mobile that day
and i walked out of the barber shop and
my ears were cold
i was just like what's going on
um but it was so funny in the barber
shop because they were convinced it was
a hidden camera thing you know when i
went in and showed the picture of the
forrest gump thing uh dressed up like
sort of a you know not like forrest gump
at this point and then like just pointed
to a picture on the wall i believe it
was number 24 and the guys like he was
just like his expression was just one of
sheer like meh are you having me i was
just like are you kidding me man
and of course i didn't want to think i
was taking the piss because you know by
going there like just like
random english dude into this barbershop
you know
i i don't think there's ever been many
brawls in a barber shop but i was
probably close closest to inciting one
that than most people
and uh he just went uh if that's what
you want they sat me down and like sort
of i swear i could actually hear that
like the chunks of hair hitting the
floor it's just like
it's like what am i doing
but you're gonna do something like this
if i'd have run it and like the whole
time i was in like perfect like sort of
bespoke sports kit
and i just was like you know
not cutting cutting my
hair and like making sure i was clean
shaven so yeah it wasn't getting all
sweaty and crusty
i'd have regretted that so much why
i think it's just like if you're going
to do it
this is if i succeeded will anybody be
bonkers enough to try it again because
it's not as if it's like the 100 meters
at the olympics it is on a four-year
cycle this was a thing it was it was a
dream but it's also
extremely far
and extremely difficult logistically to
pull off like i still swear
people said like what was the one word
that
describes how you got through the run
and like people are expecting things
like grit resilience i just go look
and there was so much luck involved in
every turn like yeah of course there was
like a lot of like effort that went into
it
but just slight missteps here you know
instead of getting hit by a car in new
jersey you know sort of um if if that
had been any worse that would have been
it you know i tore a quad in a crossing
the mississippi
and like why was that a quad injury that
i could i could walk through and then
run through rather than something that
was just like you know
look that's you out for eight weeks and
after that
did you really run continuously because
that meant a big thing to me it had to
be a continuous thing the only scooper
in that was because i wasn't american
and that's my big advice if anyone's
going to try and do it again be rich be
american and then you don't have to come
home and then and renew your visa
but i console myself with the fact that
even though people say oh well you did
have a break because you came home i was
just gonna i would have given my hind
teeth
not to come home because when i did come
back to the states
well it was back to those three weeks of
hell every single time because you'd be
trained so quickly on something like
that and i put on so much weight
um i was like ten stone two i think at
the start and i think i was ten stone
three when i finished but when i was
home if i was home for three or four
weeks i would go up to like 11 and a
half stone just because i was eating 5
000 6 000 calories a day on the run and
it took a while for my stomach not to
want that
and it was usually just about normal
level when i went back to the states and
then i had to work out how to get 5000
calories in me again
[ __ ]
so what high level what did what did you
end up achieving how long did it take
how far did you go and what were the
records that went along with that
so
the the the skinny of it was like 15
621 miles give or take you know
sometimes i i'd stop for the wii and
then remember to not start me watching
so at the start i was so obsessed with
doing this right i would actually run
back 400 meters to the point where it
had me weak and then do it but towards
the end probably just like i think for
us i was getting a bit sick of it you
know i'd be like
if i was gonna cheat i wouldn't have
cheated by 602 meters yeah so only ago
and i didn't have quite the spring of my
step at that point
it was 422 days that's an average of 37
miles a day that's like roughly a
marathon and a half and we'll call it
marathon and a half because i would end
up having to like walk to places and get
me food and stuff like that
and it was 43 different states but there
was probably about 60 65 state crossings
and 33 pairs of shoes
inc including the nike cortez which i
wore as a ceremonial thing at the start
whenever i reached an ocean
um and we talked about boston before i
actually did boston marathon uh
competitively as part of the run i
almost got to the start line but when i
tore my quad it put me back by about a
week in terms of pace
and um so i ran the boston marathon got
lift from new jersey from a local runner
and then he came and dropped me back
there like a couple of days later and i
then ran to boston and ran the marathon
but with no crowds this time which was a
real surreal moment because you're going
that's the fire station
and this that you know last time there
was like some you know six thousand
people here i went past wellesley
college and there were no signs that's
nothing to kiss anybody you know no no
snogs well
there was none in the competitive
marathon and this time because
i had a little bit of a silly um
silly idea around mile 11 when i went
past that fire station because there's a
guy in a manchester united shirt and i'm
a liverpool supporter so i saw that he
was heckling some people but in a nice
way i thought i'm going to go over and
have some fun here and when i went over
i saw he was actually offering people
some of his bud lights and so i just go
past knightscope thanks very much mate
take the whole bottle and i'm running
along mile 11 and i'm drinking away from
this beer and there's a sort of
unwritten etiquette in a
marathon running if you don't get to an
aid station because you're right in the
middle of the channel generally they'll
be a runner next to you just going to
make you on some of this water and so my
instinct was just go to the fellow next
to me mate do you want some of this he
just just looked at me like i had two
heads and he was like no
it's like okay
so
i drink this beer
over the course of the next mile
and then i'd started right at the back
because i got like a late entry
and i thought
what pace have i got to do to get under
three hours for this marathon because i
i thought the start right it's all about
preservation you're doing a much bigger
run don't be an idiot and run fast in
boston but then the crowds there it's
the reason why people should do it like
so good i was just like oh my god i've
got to give it some beans here and i i
saw what the pace was it was going to be
just over six minute miles
i did one
and it felt all right so did another one
and i ended up getting in under the
three hours and i
got interviewed by cbs at the finish
line unfortunately i didn't have the
beer on me but uh they knew about it
man that's taking scouse culture
international that's exactly what a
scouser should have done how did you get
on with your marathon well i nabbed a
beer halfway around and i finished it in
under three hours
exactly well bud light's just an
isotonic sports drink really though
isn't it so everything everything is
fueled all right so you have got this
plan in place you have an understanding
that you're going to get yourself from
alabama where you begin
up to austin texas or up to texas to
pick up your rv who's with you what's
the support team look like and what's
the kit that you take out
so i had a really excellent support crew
i had a driver i had a crew chief i had
a navigator a psychologist
and the only issue with that was it was
just one person and that was a that was
my long-suffering girlfriend nadine who
took on every role
that was needed and um i don't think
she'd ever driven a left-hand drive
before and certainly neither of us had
ever driven a 30-foot left-hand drive of
one of the busiest interstate systems in
the world and then
i love the fact that the guy in houston
who was there he sold zrb was a guy
called randy lane which is the most
texan name i've ever heard of your life
he had a huge tash he had a proper like
stetson and stuff like that and to be
fair to him like there were a few issues
with the rb but
you know we were spending like sort of a
you know eighteen thousand dollars on on
something that would have probably cost
about 150 000 when it was new you know
so
we we didn't blame randy for that and
then yeah and so
natas likes it was just so good on the
on the run and it because of course like
it was my dream
and i was seeing all these incredible
sights but of course a lot of the time
she was just sat in the rv and it was
hot
it was really hot so um yeah
i i had a diamond with me it's a team
sacrifice across the board so all right
you get you get yourself out there first
three weeks you get running what was
some of the first things that you
managed to encounter between on that
first leg to get yourself out towards
santa monica
it's just one of these things where
everything was so new to me like i
remember like starting like the first
day we found a house that looked very
much like the gun boarding house and the
local tv crew came there and i was
dressed in the chinos the check shirt
the cat
and this is the actual cat by the way
you see it's a nice pink there
but
that's the inside of it so that's just
the sun that has there bleached that so
much so i had seen some seen some sights
this
and then uh the next day it turned into
a proper like sort of you know monsoon
and i was running through like sort of
half high water
but then you just get into proper bayou
country and i was listening to credence
and i was soundtracking my life and uh
got into mississippi first of all i
crossed the great state of alabama and
then got into mississippi and i saw the
roadkill thing on the road ahead of me
and i thought it was a deer
it's only when i got close to it it was
like a six foot gator but you know
basically so
all the bones were there but then you
can see the scales and then
i was going to take one of its teeth as
like a little thing and you know make it
to a necklace afterwards and just as i
went down to touch it a huge flock of
birds just scattered and i just thought
oh man there's some bad food about this
i haven't believe in that right there
you know
but um yes i i just sweated my way to
texas and
ironically the first hint of a trouble
came as we were approaching houston
uh i had a good school pal i've not seen
20 years comes out and runs with me for
a couple of days
and we're sitting around there having
lunch and the dean just says to me you
are smashing this said you're going to
do this so easy and i was hey i was
still getting tired at this point by the
way um
and i said we'll say that when i'm about
10 miles from the end and i got up from
this chair and i've had this um pain in
my uh my shin for the last couple of
days
and i got off and i heard like this
creaking noise
and i just said right after the chair
and then i carried on walking and i
could hear my leg was making a noise and
it was basically my tendon so inflamed
within the sheath that it was actually
rubbing that much it was like it sounded
almost like a cricket and i was just
like oh my god and then
i did all my google and i spoke to
physio in liverpool and he said this is
like an eight week layoff type thing um
what can you do in terms of rest and i
said uh well i've got tonight
and um so i spoke to chris the guy who'd
run across
before and he'd looked at all my like
sort of strava data and he said rob
you're running too fast and nadine told
me that as well but like i didn't feel
it at all i was just like this is great
i'm not out of breath i'm sweating but
because it's like 40 degrees
um and he said you just need to start
taking walking breaks in the day and he
said i said i'm not walking across
america i'm running across america and
he goes yeah nobody who runs across
america runs the whole way he said you
have to recover on the job because if
you don't your body's you know what what
you're expected to do it can't rebuild
while you're breaking it down
simultaneously you've got to give it
some sort of a chance
and somehow i sort of physio in houston
and i just love the fact that she was
called whitney you know and it like yeah
it only dawned on me after i'd left you
know it's like one of these things where
you have an argument and then you you
think of the best thing to say in the
world and like yeah so whitney houston
saved my life
um
i got to el paso the other side of texas
and that's when i started just to fall
in love with the hot with the desert you
know because it's just great i had one
day where i was running down this hill
and then i was sort of back and forth
with two um mexican vaqueros cowboys who
were on a 60 mile ride that day and um
we just like like proper road warriors
you know like we tip our hat to each
other as we passed each other in there
yeah like get getting through texas with
something huge to me because the biggest
thing in distance in the uk is probably
a landsat johnny groats so for like
people listening abroad that is the very
top of scotland to the very bottom of
england
and just to go across texas he's about
50 miles further than that so i was like
this is this is the achievement and when
i got injured after that i got uh
achilles tendinitis in phoenix
but i didn't care because i just thought
well i'll take it off i could take
machine up but i've still run across
texas and that's what gave me the
confidence that i wouldn't have been
super you know lifelong disappointed uh
if i hadn't done the whole thing you
know it certainly would have had enough
to look back on i think i'd have only
got a um
upset about it when somebody else did i
remember then you got a great podcast
about sort of uh people who achieve a
lot and sort of uh but they also can
tend to be very jealous now i'm just a
bit like no no i'll be absolutely fine
apart from when i read it in the paper
that someone's done it
so i couldn't stop that it's a great
source of motivation where are you
sleeping once you've picked up the rv
are you parking up somewhere by the side
of the road or finding a truck stop and
then just keeping in the rv overnight
yeah well you came up with two of the
three options there so the third option
would be the campsite we'd have to do
that every three days because you've got
like your gray water which is like your
shower water and your your dishes and
things like that and you got your black
water which is the other type of water
that you need to get rid of from it and
then so
i knew that sort of nadine was going to
be you know the one for me for keeps
when we are both holding a pipe and uh
seeing sort of the previous day's meals
disappear in front of us
um
yeah who thought that rv was so
glamorous right
um but sometimes we'd stay at truck
stops and then we had we had a hilarious
time uh we're in kingman arizona which
is on route 66
and the
unwritten rule of rvs and truck stops is
you do not park where trucks should be
because you know they've got sleep
they're doing a job you know and if they
if they don't rest they're dangerous and
so they're just like you know i couldn't
believe there was a bully trailer there
when i arrived so we get to this place
and it's empty so we just park up
randomly and we've gone to bed about 10
o'clock and we shouldn't get a hammer in
on the door and it's this truck driver
and i'm just like mate what's the
problem and it just goes you're in my
spot and i was just like are they
reserved it just goes i just want to
park here move your rv and i just
thought i am not arguing with the truck
driver and so we moved it over the road
now we just filled up with petrol that
night and first of all it wouldn't start
and we're like oh my god so it's got
like an emergency start button which
gives it a massive push yeah it got over
the road and we noticed that the fuel
had gone down to zero and i just saw
this bastard stone i feel and i was i
was bouncing off the walls and i went
over and it was in the service and said
if you've got cctv like on the car path
and you're like yeah and i was like boo
police said yeah we've been here
someone's stolen our fuel and then so
they come round they take a photo the
fuel gauge they get access to the cctv
it's quite late um and then he said
we'll come in and see you in the morning
so in the morning they come and knock
and they're going hi how are you like
great because we were a bit worried this
guy was going to come over and do
something anyway you know and then so he
just says yeah we just need to like you
know
move you or something i can't remember
he did return the ignition and the fuel
needle just go ding ding ding ding ding
ding i was a pretty stuck needle wasn't
it
and the thing is it was so good that
that was the copper who'd seen it
empty the night before with the engine
running and i was just like may i'm
really sorry is this a problem and he
just like closes his notebook and he
goes not for me
and uh so yeah truck stops were great
generally because i actually i love the
chuckies he was like the only mean one
that i think i encountered the whole way
you know to be honest he was probably
just tired and he didn't want to walk
further to the bathroom so i'll let him
off
um but then the other places um and the
team was an expert finding these
was like the the rogue camping so
it was so great in the desert it's like
really hard to do in california they
don't like you there the fourth category
is walmart car parks you know they're
they'll often let the rvs park up there
because they know you're gonna go in
and buy some food but um
we we've spent these nights like in
glorious isolation you know sort of with
no light pollution just seeing all these
stars and i remember we were only a
couple of days after el paso in new
mexico and then i found this perfect
place on the sat nav and i said right
i'm going to run to this and i'll see
you there in a bit i'm going to get
there there's a border patrol uh car
parked up there and i'm just like oh no
he's so not going to let his camp here
so i knocked on the window
and he had so much armor on him and he
was so tooled up and he was little and
squat he looked like a turtle and so
like i was having to like sort of stifle
me chuckles and i said make you in mind
if we like park there and sleep it
overnight and he said no that's fine i
said we'll keep an eye out for you like
i said if you hear anything in the night
just make sure your doors are locked and
i was just like because we're right by
the mexican border so it's like you know
real big patrol area
and we're in this place and we're like
what do we do there's nothing around
here to do and we realized that we were
in an rv
in new mexico
and we got breaking bad on dvd
and so we literally we watched we'd
never seen any of it so we watched the
first series of it and we were like this
is amazing you know sort of like life
imitating art so much
and um yeah it was just
the whole sort of culture of america
like permeated the whole run
and to have something completely random
like that like i never thought part of
the culture that i would experience
would be like sort of you know all about
gangsters and meth dealing yeah you're
feeling like your own version of heist
there's scouse heisenberg running across
texas and new mexico
well that's what i thought was going to
be the trouble after that you know
because uh
eventually we'd see these border patrol
people and they they'd always stop and
check if i was okay you know i was
always expecting a bit of an extra
question like you know you seen anybody
around here like no no just me and
vultures
what was your recovery like so you're
running how many hours a day are you
typically running you said you're doing
about a marathon and a half so about 37
37 miles a day on average what's that
you're getting up at 8am take me through
a typical day
yeah i get off about eight and and so
like i'm not a morning person at all i'm
desperately trying to become it because
i just know my life would be so much
better if i could get myself up reliably
that that's my mission that's my new
year's resolution for 22. i'm going to
try and get a morning morning routine
sorted
and i'd usually have something like a
protein shake before i go out there the
door and eventually i'd actually start
throwing you know the sachets of oats i
just throw one of those in and i just
swirl it round and just get it in um i
wouldn't take any water with me on the
first run because i was probably over
hydrated overnight
get to the air do about like eight nine
ten miles
have my second breakfast which is
usually something pretty filthy uh like
donuts or like twixes elite nutrition
then
egg exactly it's real top-notch stuff
and then i actually call the gas station
nutrition because it's just literally
what we get in the gas stations and
dollar generals because you know she's
fantastic
um i do that then we go through to lunch
uh and i had this set routine every
single day apart from the odd time we go
to like a fast food joint i'd have ham
salad and catalina dressing sandwiches
now i've never even heard of catalina
dressing before i was in the states it's
like this sort of almost like a red
creamy vinaigrette and it's so nice and
and i just thought i'm having this every
day for me lunch it's going to be a
thing that i look forward to part of the
routine
and and yet like pineapple fanta as well
was was my lunchtime drink you know and
so it was so forest in its way you could
imagine that's the sort of thing the
forest would do
um
and then i'd head out you know so
generally if i could have like three
runs before lunch and marathon in the
bag that'd be great and then i tend to
do like about another you know eight or
nine miles after that and then a shorter
one but quite often it was dictated to
where the uh our resting place was that
night because
if we were at an rv park after 32 miles
i would much rather start from where we
were in the morning rather than go eight
miles past or eight miles shy and
sometimes we'll go longer uh because
then you'd have to go for the more you'd
have to drive back to the line you're
drawing the sand or the bowl that you
put on the floor you know to make sure
you did the place and i'd always go
about 10 meters back just in case it
moved in the wind you know and then and
then off we go and then
even a meal was usually like
microwavable burritos idaho instant mash
you know god if i didn't get a
sponsorship deal up there i wouldn't get
a sponsorship deal off anyone likes i
lived off that stuff
um and then yeah just pretty much
whatever i take on the gun sometimes a
handful of gummy bears and
it changed later on sort of when i was
solo that was very much more a teenage
boy left in the house with a with a
fistful of dollars and he could eat what
he wants
[ __ ] man and what about recovery were
you doing foam rolling were you doing
any sort of active recovery during the
day any stretching routines or was it
just
sleep
yeah a lot of sleep i prided myself on
getting eight hours every night you know
it was a rare occasion when i didn't and
i would do some stretching always at the
end of the day
but
the amount of stretching i did was
clearly not adequate because the second
half of the run
i was basically
i wasn't fighting fires that was started
there was just a fire and i was just
happy to stop it going out of control
because everything was so tight you know
in my pelvis and my glutes
because i just wasn't using these
muscles they just turned into like
fibrous straps whose only function was
to like trap my sciatic nerve and then
you know i'd be running down the road
sometimes and i'd literally just either
give out a scream because of like a
massive jolt of pain going down my legs
or i'd actually almost fall over because
without any pain my leg would just
collapse under me not tired it would
just be like sorry no nerve impulses
have gone to your muscle this time so
down you go son what was the longest
that you ran in a day
it wasn't actually that spectacular like
the person some real ultra runners going
oh my god like i said this guy must be a
maniac must be doing like you know 120
mile days
it was a 63 miles um in colorado
everyone just goes oh my god that's at
mountains well i was in the uh the east
of colorado which is super flat it's
it's super gorgeous as well it's like
late autumn
and i was trying to get to this place
called new rama that night um and i knew
that there was a cafe there that like
shut about six o'clock and i really
enjoyed my breaks during the day and i
speak to people sometimes i just go in
such a lovely
place i'm just gonna sit here for an
hour and watch the world go by and i
realized i wasn't going to get there for
the cafe and it was such a small town
there was not going to be anywhere that
i could ask anyone to stay no one on
couch surfing
but the post office lobbies in the
states are open 24 hours
it's because people can just like go and
pick up the mail whenever whenever they
do you notice they work so hard over
there and then
i thought right i'm gonna go and stay
there but i get to this new raymond it's
pitch black dark and i think i'm just
gonna try this cafe you never know and i
go then there's a light on i think oh
this is going to be so good i had like a
half a subway left for me dinner so i
wasn't bothered about dinner but
i was just hoping that somebody there
was going to be able to put us up and i
opened the door and it wasn't just a
cafe it was a bar and i was like oh yes
and uh i go through the door and then
this guy a fellow called jeff stelter
who's the loudest guy i think i'll ever
meet in my life he goes oh my sweet
jesus forrest gumps here praise the lord
and i just go oh i i just sit down at
the bar and he goes what's your name and
i go oh hey rob he goes robes here
everybody bro come what are you drinking
rope and so i think i got bought about
five beers and then
i said oh guys i'm gonna have to make a
move we're gonna go and like do more
running tomorrow and see like where are
you staying i was like in the post
office lobby and they were like no way
you're coming back to ours and so they
were like they're oil drivers and so
they had a trailer and they took us back
to the trailer a few more beers they
offered me uh
balls testicles pretty oysters and i was
just like i'm gonna pass on them man i
need my protein but eh not that badly
exactly and so they went oh you need
protein they just gave me a tub of
protein powder for the next day and then
and that was just great and then the
next day i think we did like 55 miles as
well and you know at the end
i i could string together like sort of
you know 10 days 50 miles and it'd not
even be a problem it'd just be like sort
of a normal day at work which sounds
like ole miss is from being like you
know
like cocky about some superhuman feet
but it that is just what the body is
able to do you know instead i wasn't
unique if i was unique imagine the
chances of the one guy who could do it
being the guy who decides to do it it's
just not gonna happen you know and so it
does show that
the limits that we perceive to be there
are only deceived that's really
important obviously that's really
interesting about how adaptable we are
so i've got a buddy will googe who just
ran you know will have you been
following his 48 30 exactly yeah
brilliant yeah yeah man so for the
people that don't know will ran 48
marathons in 30 days for his mom for his
mum yeah i think it was macmillan cancer
that he did it in collaboration with and
was it all
48 counties
in the uk
i think yeah so he ran all 48 counties
48 marathons in 30 days one interesting
thing that he talked about he did a
little bit of post-run analysis on his
running style and his stride and he has
a very short
stride relatively quick turnover but
it's a bit of a shuffle it's kind of
like a little like little steps he's not
really doing much um did you notice that
your
running form cadence at all did you
twist that and change that as the run
progressed did you find a rhythm that
was appropriate for you
yeah i think you sort of did and that's
actually one of the uh
the real niche things i know know about
the films that seven minute slice of
movie history where forrest does his run
you see him like around that corner in
greenville um and he's like you know
he's upright he's you know so he's got a
lovely sort of you know sort of choppy
cadence but he's got a great stride
length and then you still see him doing
that they said midway through uh you
know glacier national park but when it
gets to the likes of arizona and then on
to utah it's such a shuffle and for me
like
i i tried to have a a low carriage
basically because if you are sort of you
know not going up and down then there's
going to be less bang bang bang but the
difficulty about trying to alter your
gait is you're opening yourself up to
injury because you know i'd run for 38
years and so um well probably 36 i don't
think i was running when i was born like
maybe
you know i wish you could have asked me
wrong and um so i was um trying to avoid
this impact but then of course i was
probably irritating my hip flexors from
a really early stage
and then later i had to alter my gate
because i had this like awful awful pain
and so
like for the last 5 000 miles or so my
left leg would hurt with virtually every
foot strike and i was taking 60 000
steps on an average day and
sometimes my right would be upset as
well because i've been doing some extra
work for the legs so sometimes in a day
i was going to get these 60 000 jolts of
pain
and it to be honest it became noise
you know so it wasn't really you know
sort of like sort of stabbing pain it
was just out out out and you would yeah
you tell your gate to it but um
if you'd have asked me at the very end
you know if you put a suitcase ten
thousand dollars a thousand miles down
the road and said go on just another
thousand i've just gone no i'm just be
i'm done you know seven that point like
where forest turns around and he says
i'm pretty tired i think i'll go home
now
i just knew exactly sort of what he felt
like
what was the darkest place that you got
to psychologically throughout the run
there was the intense one was in houston
when that creek happened in my in my
shin and then i got to a gas station
and a lady asked what i was doing so
obviously it wasn't dressed like the
normal um
and i told i gave her one of my
handwritten cards with my social media
details on uh which is run rubble i run
if anyone wants to follow
i handed
that last one out and i realized it's
probably the last one i'm ever going to
write and that was literally a lightning
bolt to my like tear ducts and i just
sobbed like not like a little you know a
little heavy breathing this was full-on
blubbing and so the lady came out from
beyond the counter gave me a huge hug a
co-worker came out did the same i went
over the road and cried for about
another half hour before i got on with
it
but that was like an acute thing and
then once i got through texas
i don't think i was
um i wasn't immune to that sort of thing
but it would have took something pretty
biblical to have got me there the rest
of it then was just the worry you know
because i had this
the worry of injury being possible but
the financial worry was always there
it's just like i did i couldn't check
the balance i would just basically put
my card in a thing and just go worked
excellent hope for the best keep up keep
yeah exactly and then
it happened once when i did that in the
motel and they said oh i'm sorry it's
been declined and i was just like oh no
pretty certain i'm actually all right
and i looked in it was like 36
and that's all i had i was you know
maxed on my overdraft at home as well
and i was in the middle of nowhere and
again another example of likes in a bar
saving my life i went and just sat down
local one and figured i'm gonna camp
somewhere tonight uh i'll go and grab a
pint of course i didn't pay for that
pint and the bartender said where are
you staying
yeah
she took me back to ears and she had a
couch in the garage and then
i left the next morning to a really
nice note from a guy that i didn't even
meet that night and he just said i just
found it amazing what you're doing thank
you so much for like staying in our
house and so
i was just like wow if this kind of
thing happens i've got a chance of
making it so
i worried less about the money kind of
things
but
the darkest i ever got it wasn't really
dark so it was so much it was more of a
resignation
and i came home at the end of my fourth
crossing i managed to uh hit the uh the
atlantic for the final time the day
before i was due to fly home for my visa
and uh i've got some huge news from my
girlfriend she came back out uh when i
went home in the summer and then we
found out when we were in minnesota at a
tiny little place called fergus falls uh
that i was gonna be a dad and uh i don't
know how you had the energy in you when
you're doing a marathon and a half a day
how have you got energy left to pump on
a night time
this was on on a my trip back to the uk
in the summer and so i came back for
like three weeks sort of uh
after i got to chicago and uh we went to
see phil collins i'm not being funny i
reckon there were a lot of babies made
the night after that
yeah i should have actually it's a shame
to them that bee wasn't a boy we maybe
would have had phil as a middle name you
know
or fergus
exactly well that actually was seriously
debated you know
um i wanted to um call him if it wasn't
he
alexander douglas because i got uh
massively obsessed about scotland on one
day when i was running in idaho because
it was like scotland on steroids
and then i went back and i told the dean
that i uh i think we should call the boy
alexander douglas and she was just like
no not a chance and i was just like oh
okay okay i said i am name i am naming
the boy though and she was like no you
know i've i've got the name so i just
don't want my men to do
and then she told me um
she's gonna name our girl b like b-e-e
and of course that wasn't what i'd been
thinking of at all and so i was just
like okay
but now i obviously love it
the run changed after that because
i despite injury despite you know sort
of
worries with traffic despite running
through supposedly rough areas which
were always fine as they always are
unless you're doing something stupid in
the middle of the night you know it's
just normal people who live there and
everybody was super kind um
i felt bomb proof you know i had a few
near-death experiences but yeah it
wasn't fussed uh but after that then it
was like if a car got too close to me i
was like
you know i had this massive sense of my
own mortality and um then of course when
we got to san francisco uh which is
closing out third leg nadine had to go
home hey because we had no more money
left and um she just needed to go and
repair and of course she couldn't fly so
late so the fourth leg which is one that
i i called the middle child of the run
because there weren't many exciting
venues that i was gonna hit
it turned out it was some of the
absolute best moments of the whole trip
on this one but i wasn't excited about
it i knew winter was coming i didn't
have nadine there anymore and she was
now having to prepare for this baby and
so i'll go home and then you know in in
december and she's just looking like
stunning you know big old bump on her
you know and then
yeah just so beautiful and i spoke to a
mate about the fifth leg and i was like
planning the oh yeah i'm gonna do this
i'm gonna do that and he's just like you
don't want to go back do you and i just
said no not really mate and uh but i
didn't know why there was the obvious
answer
and then i was thinking oh cause i was
injured and i had no money it was still
going to be cold in fact there's going
to be more winter when i went back
because i thought it was going to be
nice and uh warm in alabama
january but no it got down to -19
and uh yeah it was pretty frisky and on
one day when it wasn't so cold in
alabama i was lying um
on my back i just crossed into
mississippi actually and it was a lovely
sunny day and i just had this eureka
moment
and i realized that the reason why i've
been so upset the whole thing was
because i knew that the finish would
mean nothing to me because nadine and b
weren't going to be able to be there you
know and so i'd be having this amazing
adventure i would finish it and then in
future years like sometimes i'll be sat
there around the dinner table telling
everybody about how amazing it was
and nadine has sacrificed like you know
so much of her time she was with me for
like about 7 000 or 7 000 to the 59 000
miles
i'd be like oh would have been great if
you're at the end and i just thought i'd
just not have her there at the end and
there was no way she could come out on
the schedule i was on and because i was
like you know scheduled to finish i
think on the
18th or 17th of march and b was due on
the 27th i was cutting it fine as it was
you know she was early
i did say to him i said even so much of
a rumble
whatever i am i will be on a plane i
will be home within 24 hours i don't
care what it costs you know so
you know i'll rub a gas station
i'll get that accent out you know
actually i'll just use my charm i'll use
my charm and there someone will buy me a
flight and um
so that never happens and what i just
said i'm going to do is like right let's
focus
i'm going to go and see first we'll see
if i can get a passport for a very young
baby and then i knew i could so i called
up nadine and i said if i come home
before
the birth would you consider coming out
almost as soon as we physically can to
uh to the finish and she was just like
is that possible could you get a
passport yeah body research that
so i decided to
get my foot down and do the distance
that i always intended to do the 15 248
miles
and get to a really cool landmark
break off with a significant distance
still to go to monument valley and come
back and then basically we're gonna have
like a lap of honor you know three of us
and um i finished twin arrows which is a
point in the film where forrest gets the
yellow t-shirt does that have a nice day
and it was such a poignant place to be
because it's like uh it's in ruins now
you know so you still got huge giant
arrows sticking into the earth but it
was just yeah
and i looked around me i completed my
miles and i just went home to become a
dad and then
kept myself busy wasn't quite on a
wheels rate but i did do a three
marathons in three weeks uh under three
hours as well and then
i managed to do the last one in a world
record for the fastest film character
ever to complete a marathon
you'd probably guess who it was yeah
and uh yeah so we flew out the very next
day from london um
b was i think three and a half weeks old
and we flew into vegas we drove back out
to flagstaff got to twin arrows and
there was
200 miles left on the clock and so we
had five days to bash that out in
man
that's so amazing so the fascinating
thing there for me is that
there's a degree
when you're being a pioneer or an
explorer um the liberation that you have
where you have nothing to worry about
dying for
was
uh what gave you the degrees of freedom
to feel comfortable
but as soon as you know that you're
going to be a father
that changes your own sense of life and
death and mortality and why you're doing
things
and to see that
to have a sample of before during and
after and be able to look at your own
psychology and say
i was a person that was carefree
bulletproof didn't feel like anything
was going to hurt me and then watch that
transform
as you realize that there is now
something bigger and greater than you
that shares your genetics that you need
to look after
that's amazing
it's almost like a fast-forwarded
version of life
because you know somebody when you like
you
you're stuck behind a car that's going
really slowly and you're overtaking it's
like sort of you know like one of the
more senior members of the population
and you think they're probably just
thinking
life is so precious i ain't going to be
bombing through this red light i'm not
going to be sort of undertaking somebody
i'm getting through today and like so
that i'm going to see my grandkids and
everything i had this like thing just
like fast forwarded it was
you know
the whole year was one year and a half
was like compacted down almost into like
into a movie of sorts
and you know it had a very spectacular
ending it had its trials and
tribulations but there was a huge amount
of you know people often say like what
did you learn about yourself
um
my answers to that are generally fairly
corny as you would imagine in terms of
like you know that i could achieve
something like very dramatic and you
know that i was you know able to do this
huge thing but that's not the
interesting answer
it was more what i just learned about
life
and the fact that you know how precious
it is and the fact that i i wasn't
caring that i got
clear cleared out by a truck in
tennessee or something like that it'd be
like but it's for these people that i'm
i'm leaving you know
and uh maybe that's the sort of thing
you know and
maybe that's that sense of
collectiveness is what we need now and
why everything seems to be going to [ __ ]
so much because
quite often in the media they're trying
to take away that collective and make
everybody either you know bipartisan or
you know sort of just at each other's
throats like you know talk about the
partisan things that when i was running
the states it was
the first leg was surrounding the
build-up to the trump election and we
actually watched that um the election
night in a saloon
in tombstone arizona the site of the
gunfight of the ok corral which i only
found out afterwards um took place at a
range of six foot you know what do you
think about a gunfight i imagine people
like behind barrels and across the
street this all took place over six foot
you know and of course and maybe not
quite the same range but the big fight
was happening in washington
and yeah and the the country was very
you know and i don't even think they
were necessarily
there for their
respective representatives it was teams
it was red blue
republic and dem
and there was so and that the media was
just like so you're either with us or
you're against us it was not like oh
well they've actually got really good
policy but we're going to make a
compromise
but the the what i found on the ground
was it wasn't like that it just wasn't
you know so of course you'd have people
who you'd speak to and you'd know that
they were a classic republican but they
didn't hate democrats and it was the
same as the other way around like the
people like in the cities weren't going
oh like trump voters the idiots you know
but you'd see that on the news and like
you like where are they finding these
people because i'm not encountering them
on the roads and i just found like a lot
of very very kind people and not just
kindness towards me because of course i
was going to receive kindness because i
was doing a mad thing
but then you'd hear about like something
they would do whether part of a church
group or like so i met this guy uh in
upstate new york who um organizes like a
group by fellas for fellas but it's not
like yeah guns hunted women politics
it's just like oh does anyone know how
to fix this trip and every year they
organize a huge collection
break into someone's house and like said
well replace somebody's fridge because
you know it's like bust or like one that
really got me and i just i keep always
thinking about it was a lady who'd like
lost their husband and of course that
was with the job the healthcare the
truck and they just went and they clubs
together and they just bought this lady
a car so she could get to work and drive
the kids around and just thought this is
brilliant and i i don't even know what
politics billy was so there you go
talk to me about the
near-death experiences what were they
oh god man nice to have you do you want
animal vegetable or mineral
um
all kinds of things well sort of um
from being chased down by a bull moose
in idaho and then i literally pinned
myself against the tree and it ducked
into the bushes about five foot before
uh it literally it was chased by a
cyclist you see and just completely
startled there's about 200 meters behind
it and then the advice is to hide behind
the tree because i got really bad
eyesight so i tried to do that i
couldn't because it was like full of
thorn bushes so basically just strap
strapped myself to the front of this
tree closed my eyes it was about 30 foot
away and then i heard this crash of
branches which i thought was it
disappearing into uh you know well
disappearing to me it was actually going
down into a river and i was just like oh
my god and that was my scotland day and
then so i put the proclaimers on after
that and like sort of i've never heard
sweet music in my life you know
um
but then of course one of the things i
mentioned before was like the cars um
you know i heard when i was running
there was a chap in ohio uh called nick
ashil who'd actually been cleaned out by
a hit-and-run driver and the only reason
he survived that they found him is that
he was on the phone to his wife at the
time and the fellow actually swerved
across the road to get him
um and they punctured his lung broke his
pelvis internal injuries everything like
that and then he's uh he's fit now and
he's gonna go back and he's gonna
complete that crossing so
i had a few things like that and i was
just sort of thinking was that
deliberate swerve it probably wasn't
it's probably a phone distraction
the biggest example of that was i had
when it was in tennessee and a huge 18
wheel wig
just jackknifed in front of me and i was
standing there i was pushing my stroller
at this point because i was so low into
this stroller carried all my belongings
i would face oncoming traffic so i was
on the left-hand side of the road there
and i was just trying to long see this
truck and then suddenly it just starts
screaming it bends double and like you
could see the steam coming up from its
wheels and i'm just stood there looking
at it i'm not scared
i'm not seeing me like flash before my
eyes i just think that's gonna make me
nice
and then and it would have done because
i was just frozen to the spot and it
stopped about 30 foot shy of me you know
so uh the guy just sort of looked up
from like his wheel and i was just like
maze you know we're both pretty lucky
boys because um
yeah i think he was on his phone
and um
yeah man like highway 190 in uh in baton
rouge and uh crossing the mississippi
for the first time it should have been a
celebration
but there was no sidewalk no shoulder
just four lanes of traffic and a 200
foot drop to the mississippi so uh
i i knew this in advance but i didn't
want to do another 30 miles i thought
it's only a mile
how bad can it be you know instead of
air we'll go through a worse mile
probably metaphorically or literally in
our lives
so i get to the point where the uh where
the shoulder disappears into a point and
i get my mp3 players
engage guns and roses welcome to the
jungle
put that on and as soon as like you know
like the lyrics kicking i go and i go
across this bridge in like sort of 5 43
and the line comes out at the end you
know where you are baby you're in the
jungle you're gonna die
i did you know i've got some excellent
youtube footage of it there and you'll
see that okay pretty close
um
the closest i actually came to genuine
death
was um
i was just crossing from state new york
into pennsylvania
and i saw this guy shirtless
must have weighed about i don't know
250 300 pounds maybe skinhead tattoos
everywhere
and then really rural and he's got this
like trash bag in his hands and he
throws it across his garden and i'm like
uh it's a bit weird why would you do
that you know he's not throwing it in
the bin he's just throwing it across his
garden
and uh or yards and he just walks up to
this bag and as he's there i see the bag
move
and i realize he's got legs and i
thought oh my god like he's just that's
his dog what do what do i say do it do i
say something i was just like stood
there watching i was about like you know
i don't know 100 feet away
and i thought no if i say something i'm
dead and uh he just strides over just
kicks it like full hunts it in the belly
and the dog lifts off the floor you know
then this is like you know 10 kilo 15
kilo dog lifts off the floor the force
he puts through it
and that is when i did engage my scaredy
scouts voice and then if you listen to
the audio book i don't think i could
actually ever
reprise it with such fury as i did on
that day but i gave it a really good go
in the audiobook we even have to bleep
things out because i went over the top
and then
i just as soon as i said it i just
thought that was the stupidest thing
you've just done in in the history of
the world
and i thought let's just hope that he
realizes that he was out of order and he
doesn't sound scary and he just goes
what did you say
and i just said oh my god i can't back
down now so i went for it again and then
uh he just starts walking over and i get
me thrown out i tried to take a photo of
him but it doesn't work and i go mate
i'm just taking a photo of you one more
step and i'm calling the police and so
he doesn't just take one more step he
just starts running towards me with this
dog wagging his tail next to him as as
it bloody would so i'm just like right
i've got to go in i'm pushing me
stroller thanking god that it was a flat
road you know and we go about 250 meters
and i realize he's not catching me and
so i sort of think
what do i do here like do i say
something else to him like mate let's
just forget about this and i thought
just just in case you didn't know me
i've done 10 000 miles so if you want to
keep going between the two of us my
cardio is going to eat you alive
well well i might have actually slowed
down a little bit to see if he was going
to carry on giving up giving the chases
because i wanted him to get as far away
from his house as possible because i
just thought oh my god if he goes back
and gets a gun
and then so he eventually bends double
but then he turns around and runs back
to his house he doesn't walk back he was
so tired he had to like you know put his
hands on his knees and breathe but then
he runs back to his house and he didn't
look the sort of uh to be doing a nice
little sort of a dinner for the local
church group on his stove and so i just
thought he's going to go and get his
truck he's going to go and get his gun
and so i'm literally steaming down this
road
knowing that he probably wouldn't have
come the whole way across the road to
clean me out but every car truck that go
past me i'm just like looking at that
skin a gasket there guys getting a guy
and eventually get to this like sort of
uh you know place and just like sit down
and like so i think i drank so many cans
of coke just because i needed like the
sugary stuff yeah exactly
and um i took a screen grab of where it
was on the map and sent nadine a message
saying if you don't hear from me within
the next 12 hours
you have to direct the police to this
point uh because they probably will find
a body or at least some evidence of
where the trail is going to begin there
and she was just like what's this about
what it's about
and i just sent that and i ran into an
area where there was no mobile reception
so that was like it you know and so it
was about three or four hours before i
could get another message back to her
your missus is an absolute saint
you know what this is a thought thing
like so i've written my story down and
everyone's just gonna go when's nads
right there but and i keep telling her
to do you know she's got some tails you
know
okay now so what happened with this pram
after a while
your missus had to go back to the uk
which meant did the rv go part way
through and then what the what would you
do
well we went we went to we
doubled back and we went to tennessee
and she was flying back from nashville
and so when we put the rv into storage
in cockfield it was actually quite weird
because um i tore my quad when i was uh
going across the mississippi the second
time
and i ended up like literally
the last half of that day i was in
memphis and i couldn't run i was walking
in memphis man and the irony of that was
not lost on me and we parked up in this
mobile home place for two days and i
woke up the next morning because you
knew me like was sure but i wasn't like
off to all because i was just like i've
got a little bit of pull
and i woke up the next morning and it
was almost as if like sort of someone
had like stuffed like an orange under me
underneath the skin it was that swollen
but then i put my finger in it it was
just like
oh no it just went back really slowly
and i just wouldn't have torn this
and then walked to like the little wash
block which was like about you know 30
meters away and i just couldn't i had to
hop after about 10 meters after hop came
back and i said we're not going anywhere
today and that happened the next day and
then
i think the dean was due to fly back in
about three days time and i said listen
i'm just gonna go to the start today
if i can't walk
you know like a good distance then i'll
just come back with you and this is it
this is our i'm pretty tired
i'm pretty torn i think i'll go home now
and so um we knew that she was going
um so i i had some preparation for being
solo it was actually a cram that i
bought in australia because i thought i
might run across australia and that
never happened the fact the first time i
ever set this thing up and pushed it was
in that mobile home park
and then i knew in four days time not
only was i going to be having to
get from a to b with a with a tall quad
i was also going to be pushing a sled
effectively you know and so just like
this is not good for a quad
and um yes i managed to do 27 miles that
day 33 miles the next day and this is
walking and then i'll gradually
reintroduce the uh the runs and stuff
when we got to jackson and we've got
like a greyhound there to nashville also
actually we drove the the uh the rv to
nashville and we put it in storage just
down the road i got the greyhound back
to jackson where i finished running and
it was just such a i felt like i was in
a bruce springsteen stone because i just
come out i didn't have my guitar but i
had this stroller folded up
and i just like put it together and then
that was it had a whole door with all my
stuff in you know spare shoes underneath
water container on the front
um
and a wing and a breath how long did you
run pushing a pram in front of you for
eight thousand miles
eight thousand and it was it pink did i
seen a photo of it and it's pink oh no
it's blue all right okay
i do have a new one though that is uh
which i which i call it red five i
called the old one um pram solo because
i was looking like chewbacca uh and so i
thought i'd continue the star wars theme
with my new one because um well i i
pushed franz solo all the way from
jackson tennessee up to maine to
complete my second crossing and then to
chicago then from chicago went home for
a bit came back and pushed it up to uh
minneapolis and that's when the same gap
this same
pram
yeah yeah i did change the tires in
chicago though i think it had three or
four punctures at that point uh
a good bit of kit to have survived going
across america twice
oh it's amazing you know and then we had
the rv all the way across the doors down
to san francisco and a friend of mine
olivia took over in um
san fran but we'd only got like you know
two-thirds of the way through nevada
and this dude who is 90 year old
obviously not fearing for his life this
guy because he was doing about 100 miles
an hour when he undertook olivia and
slammed into a driver's side door like
totally in the rv
and so i had tam solo still but i was
not set up for that and i thought i was
going to get rv cover to get down
through nebraska and you know then
i'm in relatively southern states and i
thought it's not going to be that cold
but then suddenly
olivia's just like i'll sort this out
and i'm like no i can't leave you to do
that but she was just like listen i
don't want to be holes up in a hotel
room with you like like a caged bear you
know sort of like you know walking
around so just go and sort this out and
so like a few days later i was in utah
going across the air the bonneville salt
flats which is where they do all the
speed records and then there was one
point where there was literally nothing
like no services no place to get water
for like 70 miles uh
the hot dog at the end of that tasted
pretty good
yeah and so then then i went all the way
across to south carolina it was still
with pran solo and then i went as far as
um
well just after the exact midpoint in
route 66 um in adrian texas
uh i went i think i did a marathon past
that because i'd been laid up in a in
the motel room in adrian for five days
the longest layup i had at the whole
trip and it wasn't with injury uh it was
with a dodgy hot dog and i uh i had food
poisoning oh no
yeah
six kilos
five days
[ __ ] the bed literally what about
temperatures so you've talked about
you've talked about in enduring some
pretty crazy weather was there any
extreme winds heats colds
yeah like i was quite lucky sometimes
like
i would have a massive massive tailwind
and i love uh i love headwinds normally
when i'm doing training because it's
just a bit like it's like free hill
training you know especially in
liverpool which is pretty flat
but when i had planned solo is
occasionally like sort of a pushing like
a sail into the wind you know sometimes
you'd literally just have to stop and go
just wait for this gus to finish and
then i can carry on
and uh there's a particularly cruel
moment i was in wyoming and it was
snowing and i was so tired and i just
saw i need to have a break you know i
was trying to push on like to go about
another 15 miles before i stopped and i
just thought i need to stop i need to
eat but if i stop i'll get so cold and i
sat down like behind perhaps solo trying
to get out the worst of the wind just
like sort of eating like a twix or some
some similar elite nutrition and i was
so
tired i finished it but at least i was
fed
and i'm going down the road and about
like 800 meters after that i see a sign
saying rest area and i'm like you're
kidding me and i go into it it was a
heated rest area and i'd literally just
sat there like 45 minutes in the snow
and i was it i was in there like the
toilets there and i was just like having
my hands and the head underneath the
dryer like people coming in just by
having a way on the way to like whatever
they were driving to and it was just
thought what is this hobo who's this
who's this hairy man with a weird accent
heating himself underneath the head
right yeah yeah i mean somebody needs to
be told about this
talk to me about what keeps you going
then because
i haven't heard you say
at any point here that your desire to
keep on going really started to wane it
seems like in the beginning
you had a goal of getting yourself
across to
the pacific then from there it was okay
well let's do two crossings then from
there i guess if you break past halfway
it's more about finishing rather than
continuing to do little bits but you
know telling somebody a story about
running all of this way and then being
on your own hiding behind a [ __ ] pram
in the middle of the snow
like having lost five kilos from a bad
hot dog and like what is it
that got you up and kept you moving
every single day was there a challenge
psychologically to keep on going or is
it just routine how did that work
i sort of liking it a little bit like to
a pyramid and the peak was the ultimate
you know step uh so you know but yeah
very rarely at the peak you know instead
of that has to be just an end goal so
your day to day you're always around the
base of the pyramid now that would start
with me being either in a motel room on
somebody's couch or in my tent you know
somewhere sometimes with my water
bottles just frozen
and then i couldn't stay in that tent
what would i do like lie there all day
at the side of the road you know so i
had to get to somewhere else so and
it's a bit like i i call it like uh like
my tough boss and it's a bit like you
know on a monday morning you've had a
great weekend but you're really tired
and you do not want to go to work
you can't just call up and say i'm not
coming in because they'd be like why
because i don't want to and they go well
i don't want to pay you or employ you
anymore you're fired and so you go in
and then you do it and then to be honest
a lot of the times when you go into work
you go oh god i hate this and you're in
there about now just go actually the
people i work with are really nice and
then someone will say something that you
know i'll thank you when you didn't
expect it and you know this isn't so bad
and i found i'd be like that every
morning i'd wake up i'd be tired i'd be
like there's no way i can run 40 miles
today but then i just go well you run 40
miles yesterday the day before so get up
and do it you know you're idiot what
you're going to do liar all day you know
you've got it you've got to get to point
b you can't stay at point a you can't
afford to stay at point a for a start
so i would just you know sometimes it
literally was as much as that you know
if maybe if i had an extra 40 bucks in
my pocket i might i might have called it
but i was like no there is no option
not to do this so you just have to do it
then the best thing you can do is to
make it as fun as possible so you would
go what are my good things going to be
and in the morning you'd quite often
hear a lot of nature before like the
world was too like you know up and about
and then i would like get into music
some days i would select certain artists
i had a rule that i could never walk
when ac dc were playing so if i ever
selected ac dc for the morning that was
gonna be a big morning you know
that would dig me out of a hole like
bowie took me out of a hole emotionally
a few times nick cave did as well
and then it'd be things like well it's
only two hours to launch two hours and
ten miles so get there and i know that
there's a particularly like good fast
food joint there you know and if there's
going to be air con and it's hot or it's
going to be heating when it's cold
and then like oh it's going to be the
end of the day soon and i'm couch
surfing tonight so you you go you stage
the stage and then suddenly like in
three days i hit state line so those
three days would be golden because you'd
be getting there and then soon it'd be
an ocean
now it's not just this relentless
progress like people ask me if i ever
wanted to quit and it generally would
have been probably after the first two
legs that would have been a thought
almost every day especially when i was
on my own
you know
i just there's no way i'm gonna finish
this let's jack it in
but
i had two major reasons we're getting to
the top of the pyramid here now they
were the two charities that was running
for um
in the film they asked forrest he's
running across the mississippi such a
central feature for my run and the film
um
are you running for women's rights the
homeless world peace the environment and
animals and he gives the line
i just felt like running
um and so i did i must have done
otherwise i was in the wrong game
but i wanted to get some charities that
ticked all those boxes and uh so i chose
the world wildlife fund which does the
environment and animals and peace direct
which is a small charity uh but it they
basically
um they do things like rescue child
soldiers from the congo but provide them
with homes and jobs afterwards they
empower women and educate women in
zimbabwe a very traditional like macho
society and they basically
just they bring peace and you know in
the truest sense of the word not like
absence of war
but pieces actually got very different
meaning it's basically just being like
that one and they allow families to be
families and it's just such a wonderful
thing and then the the patron of peace
directors mark rylance and so is it
don't care bridge of spies
and
i got a video one day and i just went to
the rv and i was just like that's i
think you need to look at this and it
was like a video from mark rylance just
going thank you for all you're doing you
know in the pursuit of peace and i just
thought jesus christ man if like
someone like mark is is saying this
about me there's no way i can quit and
so my tough boss then wasn't just you
know beast him he was also an arm around
my shoulder as well you know he's an
encouraging boss and
he would like sort of you know
i i would take sort of great solace in
the things that went well uh rather than
just going off thank god nothing bad
happened today i was just like oh look
you've got from tennessee into virginia
this is brill
and um
the very top of the pyramid um
comes down to
me being a bit of a mama's boy just like
forrest and
this is matt this is my mum and she's
not around anymore unfortunately
uh she died when i was 23 and
and so she'd seen me do a few marathons
and she'd see me like sort of graduate
from uni but you know she never saw b
she never saw any of the run
but she did give me one philosophical
thing to hang my hat on which was to do
one thing in my life that made a
difference
and
it's so transpired that
all of these little sort of things came
together all these little pieces of the
jigsaw and it was when i was in the
early stages of it because i i never
really thought i would definitely do the
forest go front and i didn't have those
charities lined up and then i just
thought this is just all too perfect i
went hang on this is the thing i've
maybe been subconsciously searching for
for like 15 years
let's try and make a difference and
there's one thing that will make you
get out of bed and that's not want to
let your mum down isn't it so uh
whatever she was i'm sure she could see
me and her i know that if she was there
if she was in the rv and one day i was
saying
i'm just gonna sit off today i'm not
gonna do it she's just like you're
bloody not get out i'll kick you out
man that's so beautiful
that's so such an awesome story so talk
me through reintegrating
upon finishing what were the emotions
when you finished and then how do you
integrate back into a normal life in the
uk
yeah like so i had like two finishes so
today you know one when i got to the
distance and the only person that saw
that was a friend of mine ben who was
doing some filming and
he's put together a really cool
documentary that should hopefully see
there there the light of day next year
and that was so personal because that
was the one that
that was the one for my mum because
that's what i said i would do i would do
15 248 miles and i was in bits then
actually saying this like i'm on camera
and just go oh my god i don't know what
i'm going to be like at the proper end
but i realized that the end was going to
be more of a celebration rather than
anything else and i knew that dean and b
were going to be there i knew i had
people who were coming like my my school
friend who heard the creek you know so
if he he was coming over from san
francisco uh people who i met in alabama
and south carolina were coming out and
of course i had a very big surprise up
my sleeve at the end and so that was um
it was all about making it perfect and
just getting there and i got to the
exact point
when
where forrest finished turned round and
i said the line and then of course i go
through the crowd and say hey guys you
should probably come stick with me
something cool is about to happen
don't get too close though and um i went
and sought out nadine and um
the only sort of reward i could give her
in that sense was to thank her for
everything that she'd done and for being
so awesome because there's no way it
wasn't even just a physical support she
would have been completely within her
right tonight offered as well completely
within her rights to have said
sorry mate you've got bigger fish to fry
now you've got to come home you've got
to do this you know and so uh but she
said she would never have dreamt of it
so i am i got down on one knee not just
out of timeless uh you know and uh and
asked her to marry me and she
fortunately said yes unfortunately i
could get up afterwards and then yeah it
turned into a proper old celebration
loads of the local navajo reservation i
just i love the navajo so much you're
just such a genuine people you know and
they helped me so much in those last few
days
and then to have like my proposal at
that point
you know a very elaborate staged one but
you know it just it just felt right you
know sort of i felt like the right
people were there you know
and um yes so we came back and normal
life and i remember seeing a there's a
there's a facebook group called usa
crosses and it's about people who've
like sort of uh
run or walked across the states and i
remember seeing a post there saying how
is everybody dealing with you know stuff
after the run like i'm like really
really struggling and i was reading this
going oh that's interesting and well
well i said before about me feeling that
was bomb proof you know
and i thought i'll be fine you know
because i i've you know changed jobs in
the past i'd moved country and survived
breakups and survived you know you know
the deaths of like my closest family and
i came through and that's fine i was
just like no that's not going to bother
me
of course i didn't post that because
that would be the act of a douchebag you
know uh but i just thought what a shame
these people are feeling like that and i
was
because my finish was so euphoric and
because i had this lovely new baby and i
thought oh we're gonna be getting
married you know um
it took quite a while for me to realize
i was in a really deep hole
you know so i was really quite you know
i i turned into a grumpy heart bastard
you know slovak basically you know where
where the joke would happen in the past
i wouldn't respond in the same way
and i realized it was and i hated work
even more even though my new job was way
better than my previous one
it was just this sense of like an
ultimate freedom that i had on the run
and it wasn't there anymore i said i
didn't resent looking after my little
girl it's the best thing ever but it was
like one of these sort of things where
physiologically but he's just like why
aren't you doing this man where's the
endorphins at
exactly and then but the thing is you go
through that and like the whole you know
when they say oh when did your olympic
gold sink in and they got i don't think
it has yet and you just think well a
load of rubbish
it was sunk in the moment you were
drinking that third bottle of champagne
you know but it's really not like that
and i think sort of when you just like
when you experience a massive trauma i
think if you experience a massive like
sort of high like that
it does take a while for everything to
level off and i'm
so sort of happy that that's happened
now and then
uh i will be putting it behind me in a
rather unique way in a few months but uh
we should probably get to that what what
what can you tell us about that
so i am planning to go out to monument
valley once again and
i am always wanting to run across
america and there's always been a thing
that was just going because forest just
finished in the middle of nowhere and as
you walk through the crowd they're like
now what are we gonna do and i always
thought about you know so what did he do
after that what did those people do and
i still want to go out and i want to i
want to see the people sort of being
cayenne
my navajo friends you know i want to run
to that ocean one last time
i think it would have to be in santa
monica because
if you're a fan of the film
uh you'll notice at the start a single
white feather floats into the scene and
at the end it floats out
and i just reached my uh first ocean in
santa monica and chris finnell the
fellow runner said it doesn't count
unless you get in the sea so uh i
stripped off it was there november the
30th it was almost five years like the
day that we're talking and then got in
it was freezing cold and um
i came out i just put my clothes on i
was just like who put that there and
underneath my nike cortez was a single
white feather that nobody had done
everyone's just i literally had just
blown in there and i was just like this
is so true and showtastic it's
unbelievable
and so um yeah i think sort of that
would be the way that i'll get a nice
sense of closure and i've obviously
discussed it in depth with nadine and
i'm hoping to persuade it to come out
because i do think sort of uh i think
disney world will definitely be on the
cards
now uh but obviously i'll be doing it in
a bit in a different way this time i
don't think i'm going to be um
pushing it as hard on the miles i'm not
going to be running at night unless i'm
in the desert in the middle of nowhere
you know i always actually wanted to
have one night where i just ran through
the desert you know start running at
sunset see a sunrise
um and then just get there and see the
ocean and instead of turning around this
time just go for a slap up dinner
man and then what about australia have
you got any intentions to do anything
over there
oh that that's a that's a big burning
thing like stuff like um
focused on america at the moment like
one of the things i do want to do is
obviously you know it's another
opportunity to try and raise a shed load
of money for peace director wwf as well
but
talk about wwf australia it's like you
know it's almost climate change in a in
a just a microcosm is it from the
barrier reef through the fires through
the droughts
and
they would work very well here's them
over there you know to try and see those
landscapes and i felt so at home in
australia like
you know i can say i'm australian
champion
and that makes me australian like even
if it's not by birth you know like i'm
really quite proud of the adopted son
and
yeah exactly and then i think only one
person's ever gone um the whole way
across from the most eastern point to
the most western points to the most
eastern point
and then i think i wouldn't mind that
yeah i'm quite happy being the second
one there [ __ ] well i mean the outback's
gonna be significantly more remote than
even the most remote place in america
right you've just got hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of miles with
absolutely nothing
yeah like the most remote point the
place i was it was with wyoming and
basically you were looking like sort of
um 40 miles was the sort of the you know
the minimum really before you get
anything like a gas station but yeah
there's a single road in australia that
is 93 miles long
absolutely straight and if it wasn't for
the curvature of the earth if you shot a
laser pointer at one end you would see
it at the other end and so uh
i want to do that road in one day that's
going to be that's pretty
hardcore
yeah
i want to draw a little line at the
start myself but if i've got a crew i
want them to go and you know like when
you get to the end of a formula one
track and you've got a little checkered
flag on the end i just want that then
australian bbq australian gump i'm all
about it
with instead of the bubble gum pepper
it's gonna have to be one of those
little sort of egg you know the hats
with the cork hanging down yeah there's
australian people feeling like we're
appropriating their culture at the
moment but
i'm australian champion
it's fine i'm allowed to do it rob tell
people where they can go to watch and
learn more about this it's such an
amazing story and the audible book with
your uh beautiful scouse accent adding
an extra bit of color to it must be
amazing
exactly as i said i mean because because
it is generally
at the end of the day this is a love
story it's love for the film it's love
for the dnb but it's also
a love letter to the people of america
and the country it's not about making
america great again it's about stopping
america going down the tubes because
america has got infinite potential it
always has and it always will be we just
got to stop this narrative that you know
everything's bad yeah it's got problems
we've all got problems but america's got
it to solve and so yeah it's all about
love and uh we need more of that in the
world and this is uh this is the
becoming forest the book uh it's out in
all your shops uh it's out in australia
and new zealand i think on january the
5th and out in america on february the
8th but you know you can if you're
desperate you can get it from
alternative bandit sources now
man and what about if people want to
keep up to date with you websites
socials all that yeah
so um
like run forest run i'm run rob la run
so rob la and i'm on i'm on most things
i'm not i'm not doing the old tick tock
yet but i think if i do go back to the
states in february i think i could
probably have to dip my toes in that
water you're gonna need a translator for
the people on tick tock to understand
maybe i'll just lip sync the songs man
i'm head that's all the rage just do a
dance dude this has been this has been
really really amazing i love the story i
love what you've done i love the fact
that it had a higher purpose it seems
like it's been
the keystone
moment that so much of your life before
and after a little bit of closure and
then a genesis for something new i think
it's a really really beautiful story man
i'm really excited to see what you do
next
thanks very much mate thanks for letting
me tell it my pleasure what's happening
people thank you very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that episode then press
here for a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few weeks
and don't forget to
subscribe peace